there's some breaking news to tell you  this afternoon dame president dick is to  continue to lead the metropolitan police  until 2024 confirmation just in from the  home secretary pretty patel she had a  five-year spell but has now been granted  a two-year extension plenty of criticism  a number of people had called for her uh  for that not to be extended including  baroness dorian lawrence lady diana  britain of course the widow of former  home secretary leon britton former  conservative mp harvey proctor and  broadcaster paul gambaccini all  expressed disappointment or criticism of  police over cases affecting them but  confirmation then dame cressida dick is  to stay as net police commissioner for  another two years